[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i didn't think odell beckham jr was
going to be traded but uh i wonder if
the cleveland browns are reconsidering
that with a little bit of drama there
where obj's dad now involved in this
uh obj senior is involved in this uh
let's uh let's start there with peter
king from football morning in america
nbcsports.com
why do you why didn't you think he was
traded pete
who's got the money for odell beckham i
mean dan the biggest problem at the
trading deadline this year
is that
there were record number of teams within
five million dollars of the salary cap
or less
the rams really wanted von miller but
they told the broncos listen
we have we have no money and we've
already redone all the contracts that we
can the only way this gets done is if
you take the vast majority of his money
the rams paid an extra third round pick
for von miller because the broncos were
willing to pay 9 million of the 97 that
was left
so with odell i mean
trying to figure the number now i wrote
it in my column a week ago
uh that if anybody wants them basically
they got to commit uh whatever 21
million bucks to them over the next
three years and including this year
and it's just i mean does anybody really
want to do that for a guy who a gets
hurt a lot b for whatever reason okay
and no one really knows but for whatever
reason he's not the receiver he was with
the giants is he not getting targeted
enough that's what he would say
uh
i mean but dan has his yards for catch
is way down from giant stays it's just
he's he's a he's kind of a mystery
player right now plus he's he's either
about to turn 29 or 29 so
you know i don't know i
teams without money
and not knowing what guy you're getting
when you trade for odell beckham i think
that's the reason why yeah but it's just
strange that he got there
and it it felt like his mind was still
in new york like he the giants sent you
to the browns they wanted to punish you
and he kept like i'm gonna prove you
guys wrong i mean they're a contender
he he he could be a media darling like
you want out of a situation that you
would want into a situation where you
got a chance to win a super bowl in
cleveland um you could be the star of
this team i'm just curious when i watch
there are times when i can go a long
period of time i don't hear his name
called
yeah i think part of that is that so we
missed i think nine games last year he's
missed a couple of games this year with
injury
uh
so
dan that's that's the big question you
know who is he
and that
that the other part of this i think is i
mean when you think about odell beckham
jr
okay
you think of a real explosive receiver
and you know he just hasn't i mean he
had a couple of plays last year against
dallas
i think one was even a running play if
i'm not mistaken
uh a reverse
and you know he looked like the old
explosive odell but to me
i mean he's such a squeaky wheel
and at some point you have to determine
and i'm sure the browns have buyer's
remorse
but at some point you have to determine
if that's worth it and i'm sure a lot of
teams around the league
i mean look it
we might sit here dan and say
oh you know his dad doing that that's
just a father protecting his son or
whatever being a fan whatever it is i
mean stuff like that gets into a locker
room yeah do you want to trade for that
i mean he's been
he's been as disruptive
as he's been effective uh and you know
the other thing is
you know if you look at his career in
with the giants he was like he was a
touchdown machine
you know i mean this guy has scored
seven touchdowns in two and a half years
with the browns i mean he hasn't scored
a touchdown since mid-season last year
so i what are you getting dan that's the
question
what's the trade that should have
happened
but didn't
the trade that should have happened that
didn't is
uh
i think the broncos if i were them i
would have traded kyle fuller for
whatever i can get
uh you've got enough depth in the
secondary right now you're down on kyle
fuller and i know there wasn't as robust
a market for him as people thought but i
mean he's still
uh just look at all the teams all the
top tier teams in the nfl that could use
a corner right now um i thought that was
one that should have happened and did
give me the strategy behind the texans
not trading deshaun watson
i mean you gotta have two teams that
want to make a trade
if the miami dolphins really wanted
desean watson
they would have traded for him now i do
not know what happened in this alleged
conversation between stephen ross and
deshaun watson on monday night i'm not
positive it happened but let's just say
it did
you know
basically if you're if you're stephen
ross
you've got to get a commitment from
either
desean watson's people or his handlers
his age and his lawyers whatever to say
we're going to make this thing go away
we're going to make a settlement uh on
this right now
and i and for whatever reason whether
that was asked for and didn't happen if
i were the owner that's what i would
have said we'll trade for you if this
goes away
and we'll deal with the firestorm
but desean watson and his attorney
last spring chose to not settle
whether they could have or not i don't
know but he is steadfastly proclaimed
his innocence that's america but you
can't ask
an acquiring team
to acquire a superstar player and you
don't know
whether he's going to be available not
only this year but on opening day next
year
if this goes the way we think it is dan
and this doesn't get resolved until
sometime in 2022 deshaun watson's
probably not playing opening day next
year
so who would trade for that
yeah and what are you trading and and
when are you going to get him we've
asked the texans twice whose decision is
this that desean watson is not playing
is it the texans is it deshawn's is it
the nfl
and we've gotten no response what if
deshawn goes in and goes hey i'd like to
play now
it's a coach's decision and david cully
would say i'm sorry we're playing tyrod
taylor and davis mills
uh
and you know so then
you have to decide do you want to be the
ultimate squeaky wheel and start
screaming to play um i doubt i doubt he
would do that my gut feeling is this is
just going to continue as it has been
the whole year
is it tanking
is it what tanking
um is it tanking i don't think it's
tanking in the truest sense of the word
let me ask you a question dan if you
owned a football team and there was some
significant evidence
that your star had had sexual
impropriety
with any number of women up to the
number 22
and
you have to ask yourself
do i want this person wearing my uniform
that's a question that for anybody who
says oh my god he ought to be playing
ask yourself the question
if you would want desean watson being
the quarterback of your team right now
when he has not been found guilty of
anything yet
but
uh
you know is the is are the accusations
so
i whatever words so reprehensible
that you uh that you would want him that
you could you could overlook them and
have him play for your team i i wouldn't
want to why not suspend him
you don't need to
but you're paying him i think that's
where people are you are paying them but
but if you suspend them the nfl or the
nfl pa
is just going to challenge it and the
nfl pa is going to say
this man it's america he's innocent
until proven guilty nothing has been
found guilty the nfl pa would win it uh
you know there's i don't see any
alternative if you're not going to play
him
it'd be if you don't want to play him
it's just like the keyshawn johnson
thing with gruden the last six games of
the year they just told them hey stay
home
and they paid him for not coming because
gruden hated keyshawn so much and
thought he was disruptive
and
you know
i i
if if you suspend them and don't pay him
you're going to have
the nfl pa all over in the nfl pa would
win
talking to peter king football morning
in america columnist nbcsports.com
you mentioned
john gruden with john gruden out with
what happened with henry ruggs they're a
competitive team
um
how do you sort of handicap what the
raiders are going to be able to do the
second half of the season here
well
here's the thing about the raiders all
right i i mean to me
the reason why
this
hurts them right now especially
is because they had figured out the
sweet spot with henry rose
and what i mean by that is they had
figured out
that
we're not going to play him every snap
because physically he's just not up to
it
and so
they had gotten great production out of
him i mean
he was the modern day cliff branch
and he was going to have a great career
and now
now that he's gone now you ask yourself
so what are they going to do i think for
the short
term zay jones is probably the guy who
will play
in his spot sunday against the giants
but i would expect if deshaun watson
clears waivers
uh by by i think
it is thursday at 4 p.m might be
wednesday at 4 p.m because he wasn't
traded in time i think it's he's got to
clear waivers by thursday at 4 p.m
and if he does i would expect the
raiders to be very interested but
the raiders are hamstrung like so many
teams right now they're 2.6 million
under the cap so if they were to sign
desean jackson
they would have to get him for bargain
basement
and so and and you don't know right now
i don't know how much mike mayok thinks
of
desean jackson but it's a very very
logical
substitute especially for a team that's
better than we all thought they'd be at
mid-season
what did you make of the rams strategy
in uh trading for von miller
it fits everything that they do
they
figure that we'd rather have a proven
veteran
than an unproven rookie
even if it's like for two picks
you know you look at what happened with
uh jalen ramsey
and and i forget what number picks they
were that they traded but who wouldn't
take the best corner in football for two
low ones
or whatever the deal was and
i think it's the same thing with von
miller
they will trade essentially
let's make it up dan the 60th and 95th
picks about somewhere around there
uh
for von miller
they will play him
sparingly i think they're not going to
play him every snap now because they
this is a trade for january and february
dan it's not a trade for november
and so
they want him
to be fresh
when they're trying to beat tom brady in
the divisional game in january
have you touched base base with uh john
gruden
no
no i've not spoken to him
what if the jets have found their
quarterback and that quarterback is not
zach wilson
i think this is a very interesting game
on thursday night because if mike white
plays great and if somehow some way they
win
i don't think there's any way salah is
putting zach wilson back in the game a
week from sunday when he's healthy just
i mean that's my guess
uh how could you
if the guy plays two great games in a
row and
your franchise future guy had been
struggling the way zach wilson was
um
but that's something that
um i think it's easy to say what if
but we just don't know because the games
haven't been played i wouldn't expect
that mike white would play great again
um on the road a loud environment uh
colts playing for their season
um but you know you never know i i do
think
that robert saul is a lot more
interested in winning
than he would be interested in putting
sav on the hurt feelings of zack wilson
however i know you're a big baseball fan
i mentioned when the braves were
celebrating last night one of the things
i thought about is do we move on now
from the astros of 2017. you've only got
a couple players left el touvey is still
you're going to lose they'll lose the
shortstop
yeah they'll lose correa now
so there will only be two big guys left
and you know it was funny dan
you know the fenway crowd was killing
the astros during the playoffs
and this thought occurred to me the best
players on the astros in that playoff
series were all guys who were
either not even in their organization
they might have been in college or high
school but i in 2017
where was jordan alvarez you know
uh
where was fromber valdez i mean you know
these guys they walk in and they said it
reminds me of george what george young
used to say when there'd be some
controversy involving the giants that he
had nothing to do with
he would say what did i do i'm just
sitting around here picking my nose and
there's a crisis
and it's just those guys have to be
thinking man you're picking on the wrong
guys
yeah i just don't know i think dodger
fans are going to keep that uh never let
go but i don't know if other fan bases
really care since the astros lost to the
braves i you know what the yankee yankee
crowd will be the exact same way yeah
you know
the astros are kind of fortunate that
they don't play the dodgers
how often do they play them once every
three years i don't even know how the
inner league schedules work but
obviously they go to the bronx once a
year
and that crowd will never let him forget
it but and that'll happen long after you
know jose altuve will be in a retirement
home and the yankees will still be
killing the astros every time that an
astro walks into yankee stadium uh one
other thing i forgot football was
i thought maybe the saints would reach
out to the broncos since they're having
a you know a fire sale and bring back
teddy bridgewater
um now there's uh a report maybe that
philip rivers would be interested in
playing for the saints what do you think
sean payton does the rest of the season
at that position
i talked to him at length on sunday
night dan i didn't get the impression
that he thought the answer for at
quarterback was outside the room
i'm not saying that it can happen
but the other part of it is
the saints don't have two nickels
the saints are one of two teams in the
nfl right now who are under a million
dollars for the salary cap you think
phillip rivers is going to play for
dimes
i mean
played for 25 million bucks last year
uh and i doubt sincerely that they would
move heaven and earth for a guy who
might be their quarterback after he
practices for a while for what seven
weeks and maybe the playoffs i'm telling
you
sean payton
thinks that he can manage a game
with trevor simeon and he thinks he can
use taste some hill he might have tasted
he'll start i don't know
but i think he's okay with those guys
uh now if he gets one of them hurt then
he has to go to ian book
and then he might be in a little bit of
trouble even though he does love ian
book
but having said all that my gut feeling
is that they're not going to look
outside for quarterback great to talk to
you again pete thank you have a great
week hey dan thank you that's peter king
football morning in america columnist
nbc sports